ten o'clock back the other way for the  Bucks goes to his left spins back it in  blah blah  keep an eye right here now this is just  a great move by the terrific block by  Horford with the block and on the break  eating up ground with those large sticks  kind of lost his balance and miss the  shot in Middleton staring down laurels  see there is there's that three men  three green shirts again and they ripped  got it's a three on once he makes that  move to help out all right Horford is  excellent and finding space Yanis  blocked by Horford always sent it back  flying over the points in everything  else just watch says he lets them get a  half ahead of